TONY PADILLA: The guys at
Aperiodical launched a little
competition to find the integest
sequence 2013.
It's a little bit fun.
It's not a serious thing.
But basically, they've looked at
the online encyclopedia of
integer sequences and they've
basically run a competition to
see which one is the best.
And it's based on various
categories, like aesthetics,
novelty, explicability,
completeness,
these sorts of things.
But it's just a bit of fun.
But we thought we'd go through
these sequences.
And I'm not going to tell you
which one I like best, so I'll
leave that to the end.
I'm going to do my best
poker face to try
and keep it a secret.
So the first one in the sequence
is to do with the
decimal expansion of a
particular constant.
So the decimal expansion of
Khinchin's constant is the
following 2.6854.
OK, so that doesn't look
very exciting, just
by looking at it.
Khinchin's constant is a
remarkable number, actually.
Basically, if you take any
number, or almost all numbers
to be more precise-- almost
all numbers--
and you work up the
continued fraction
expansion of that guy.
So for example, we just take a
general number, x, and we can
know that we can write this
is a0 plus 1 over a1
plus 1 over a2 plus--
and so on.
You keep going on like this.
This is called-- these are a0,
a1 [INAUDIBLE] and all those
are called the continued
fraction expansion.
Well, let's say I take the
product of all these a's.
I take a1 times a2--
forget a0--
times a3 and so on, to an.
And I take the geometric
mean, so I just take an
n-th power of that.
And I see what that gives
me as I go to infinity.
So as n goes to infinity, it
goes to Khinchin's constant.
And this is true of
almost any number.
That's amazing.
I think that's an
amazing fact.
It's almost like now, obviously,
you're going to
immediately tell me, well,
it's not true of a lot of
numbers that you know about.
It's not true of a half, for
example, because the continued
fraction expansion of
a half is not--
clearly, just any rational
number, you can get basically
any number out doing
this process.
But most numbers do, that's
the amazing thing.
Almost all numbers.
No irrational numbers will do
it, but most numbers do.
Pi, for example, is thought-- so
when you take the expansion
and calculate this number for
pi, you're expected to get
Khinchin's constant.
In fact, Khinchin proved that
almost all numbers do it.
By that, he means all numbers
except for a sort of--
potentially, an infinitesimally
small set.
And the great thing about this
is, is that k0 itself, which
seems to know about almost
all numbers,
also knows about itself.
Because it's thought, although
this hasn't been proven, that
k0, when you do this expansion
for it, averages to
[INAUDIBLE].
Then take this average,
it recovers itself.
So if you like it, if there
was a number that had--
if God had a number, it would
be this number, because it
knows about almost all of
the numbers and itself.
It's kind of like beautifully
self-contained.
OK, so next one in the
sequence, this is the
Wieferich primes.
And basically, there's only two
numbers in this sequence
that we know of, 1,093
and 3,511.
So what are these guys?
The Wieferich primes are any
prime number p, such that p
squared divides 2 to the
p minus 1 minus 1.
And it's true of these
two numbers.
We don't know if it's true
of any other numbers.
In fact, I was interested to see
if there were any higher
ones than this.
And I actually found a paper
which says that, well, they've
done a search for Wieferich
primes all the way up to 6.7
times 10 to the 15th and they
haven't found any more.
So you got these two low guys,
and then nothing all the way
up to that.
So the next one in the sequence
is going to be some
huge number if, indeed,
it exists.
Well, the reason Wieferich was
interested in them is they
seem to have something to do
with Fermat's last theorem.
He was trying to prove Fermat's
last theorem.
The reason is that Wieferich
proved the following results.
You take x to the p plus
y to the p plus z to
the p equals 0.
X, y, and z are integers.
And you say that p does not
divide zyx, then you can
prove-- this is what
Wieferich did--
that p has to be one of these
Wieferich primes.
OK, so next up is Golomb's
sequence.
So this is Golomb's sequence.
BRADY HARAN: Gollum, like
"Lord of the Rings?"
TONY PADILLA: Yeah.
Well, actually, this guy's
got an amazing name--
Solomon Golomb.
It's just the coolest names
in the world, right?
So he's actually quite
an interesting guy.
He's a mathematician that
invented pentominoes, which is
this mathematical game.
But it was the forerunner
of Tetris, actually.
So Solomon Golomb
was the guy who,
essentially, invented Tetris.
What is his sequence?
His sequence is the
following--
1, 2, 2, 3, 3, 4, 4, 4,
5, 5, 5, and so on.
And what does this
sequence tell us?
Well, this sequence kind of
knows about itself, because
the sort of n-th position in
the sequence tells you how
many times the number n appears
in the sequence.
I'll start with the
first position.
Then the question is, how
many times does 1
appear in the sequence?
Well, the answer is it
only appears once.
It can only appear once.
I couldn't put a 2 here, that
wouldn't make sense.
Then I go to the next point.
Now I'm asking, how many times
does the number 2 appear in
the sequence?
Well, you can see
that it is 2.
It had to be 2.
It couldn't be 1, because then
1 would have appeared twice
and I'd have had to put
2 here, you see?
So it kind of makes sense
that it has to be 2.
So then I go to the third point
in the sequence, which
is this position here.
Now the question I have to ask
is, how many times does 3
appear in the sequence?
But I've already said that
2 had to appear 2.
So I better put 2 there So the
number of times that 3 has to
appear in the sequence
has to be 2.
And so there they are, the next
points in the sequence.
And you keep going.
You keep going in this manner.
This position the question is,
how many times does 4 appear
in the sequence?
Well, here you are.
It appears 3 times.
And so on and so on.
And you build the sequence
up this way.
It kind of knows about itself.
It's almost like it doesn't--
maybe it's had a bit of
therapy or something.
It really knows its inner
being sort of thing.
Now, there is a little--
another feature of this sequence
is that as you get to
very, very large numbers,
where does
this sequence go to?
Well, it goes to
the following.
The n-th put position of this
sequence will tend towards phi
2 minus [INAUDIBLE]
phi n phi minus 1.
Now, what is this?
OK, this is n.
What's this [INAUDIBLE] phi
thing I've written down, this
Greek letter?
This is the golden ratio.
It just appears everywhere.
So the next one are the
largest metadromes.
So what is this?
Well, a metadrome is a number
which appears in--
where the numbers appear in
a strict descending order.
Let me write down the
sequence first.
0, 1, 5, 27, 194,
1865, and so on.
It's the largest metadromes, so
the largest number you can
write where all the numbers
are in strict
descending order base n.
OK, so the first position.
This is 0 base 1.
OK, first position, so
it's going to be
something that's base 1.
And it's the largest number we
can write at strict descending
order base 1 is 0.
So this is 0 base 1.
This guy, the next one,
1, what is that?
Well, that is 1 base 2.
So it's the largest number
we could have written.
They're all in strict descending
order, base 2
because we're in the
second position.
Those two aren't
that exciting.
It gets a little bit more
interesting when you get to
the next number.
So we know what this
number should be.
Well, it's five.
But what's that?
That is 1, 2 base 3.
OK, well of course it is,
because 1 2 base 3 is
basically 3 plus 2.
Next one, keep going--
27.
This is 1 2 3 base 4, which is
4 squared plus 2 times 4 plus
3, which is 27.
OK, and you keep going
like this.
And this is how the
sequence emerges.
Well, the next on the sequence
would be 1, 2, 3, 4 base 5.
BRADY HARAN: And the next would
be 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 base 6?
TONY PADILLA: Exactly.
And so on.
I think that one's a bit
duller than that is.
That doesn't push my buttons,
unfortunately, that sequence.
BRADY HARAN: I haven't figured
out what one's
your favorite yet.
I think--
TONY PADILLA: It's
not that one.
I'll give you a clue on that.
BRADY HARAN: OK.
TONY PADILLA: OK, so
moving swiftly on.
It is all the 7's.
I think this is your favorite,
isn't it, Brady?
BRADY HARAN: I have to admit,
I don't know why--
I don't know much about it yet,
but it appeals to me.
TONY PADILLA: OK.
So what is all the 7's?
Well, it does what it
says on the tin.
It's 7, 7, 7, 7, 7, and so on.
BRADY HARAN: This is just
a nonsense sequence?
TONY PADILLA: I think it's just
a nonsense sequence, but
it's a bit of fun.
You can relate it to some math
if you try hard enough.
BRADY HARAN: I'm not sure that's
my favorite anymore.
TONY PADILLA: Have
you gone off it?
BRADY HARAN: I thought it,
actually, there was some
equation for that.
TONY PADILLA: OK, so now comes
the last of the sequences
that's been nominated, and these
are the wild numbers.
Woo, that sounds exciting.
OK, so what are the
wild numbers?
Well, they are 11, 67, 2.
There's supposed to be
an infinite number,
but what are these?
What is this sequence?
Well, it's actually a completely
made of sequence
that has come out of fiction.
There was a guy called
Philibert Schogt--
I hope I've pronounced
that properly--
who wrote a novel about a
mathematician and he solved a
problem called the wild
number problem.
So what was the wild
number problem?
The idea was that you would
take any whole number, you
would apply some--
what are described as simple
operations to that, that would
turn that number
into fractions.
And then you would keep applying
these operations
until you get back to a
whole number again.
The claim is that those numbers
that you end up with
are the wild numbers.
And of all the examples that
were supposedly known, these
were the only numbers that
were popping up.
So the question would be, are
there an infinite number of
wild numbers?
Are there numbers that
aren't wild numbers?
Well, in the book, apparently
3 is a tame number.
It's been proven that this
can never be reached.
And what the guy in the
story does is--
his idea is that he proves--
he's supposed to be a mediocre
mathematician who's
disillusioned with his career.
But he proves that there are
an infinite number of wild
numbers, which has been this
long-standing problem.
There's a nice little account on
the archive, actually, that
we use by the author of the
maths behind it and the
ideas behind it.
He's written a novel, but this
is a paper about the novel.
So this is what he's done.
He says something quite
interesting in it, in that the
idea was there would be this
mediocre mathematician that
ended up sort of solving
Fermat's last theorem, which
of course at the time
hadn't been solved.
But of course, now it has
by Andrew Wiles, but
at the time it hadn't.
And so the idea was there's this
mediocre mathematician
that comes up with a proof
of Fermat's last theorem.
And OK, he sort of pitched this
idea to a mathematician
friend of his and the
mathematician friend just sort
of shot it down straightaway.
He Said, there's no way a
mediocre mathematician would
be able to actually
come up with--
solve a longstanding
proof like that.
It would always be somebody
who's an established genius.
Now, obviously, that's true in
Andrew Wiles's case that a
genius did ultimately
find a proof for
Fermat's last theorem.
But recently, of course, we did
a video about this prime
number theorem, the twin prime
conjectures, and that was
solved by what was essentially
not a star of mathematics.
So maybe the author's friend was
a little bit unfair there.
But anyway, it gave the author
license to then go away and
invent these wild numbers.
BRADY HARAN: So he made up wild
numbers instead of using
Fermat's last theorem.
TONY PADILLA: Exactly.
BRADY HARAN: It's a bit of a
self-fulfilling prophecy
though, isn't it?
If you do solve one of these
theorems, you become a genius.
TONY PADILLA: Well, I think so.
Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: So it's always
going to be a genius.
TONY PADILLA: Sure, exactly.
But I think the claim was that
these people would have been
noticed before because
they would have--
these theorems get built up and
you build towards them.
And the proof [INAUDIBLE].
BRADY HARAN: So you've
shown me all six?
TONY PADILLA: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: Which was
your favorite?
TONY PADILLA: It's got to be
Khinchin's constant, right?
The decimal expansion of that.
I mean, that number is just--
I'm blown away by that number
and what is it.
Conceive it-- almost all
numbers, when you take this
property to do with the
continued fraction expansion,
almost all numbers give you
back this constant.
That's amazing.
That's an amazing fact.
BRADY HARAN: Except the
numbers you and I use
almost every day.
TONY PADILLA: But that's such
a tiny fraction-- that's a
minuscule fraction of all
numbers that are out there.
It's a measure zero fraction
of it, in fact.
So the vast majority
of numbers--
the truly vast majority
do give back this guy.
Pi gives it.
Well, that's what we think.
So that, for me, is absolutely
incredible.
And so that's why
I like that guy.
As I said, if there is a number
which has any kind of
divinity to it, it's this one.
I think I read somewhere that
if we're going to send out
some information to aliens,
we should send out--
and it's going to be numeric,
we should tell
them about this constant.
So I do like that number.
But I do have a sequence, a
personal sequence that I like
more, though.
I'd like to share
with you, Brady.
BRADY HARAN: I don't know what
this is going to be.
Actually, I know what this is.
TONY PADILLA: OK, well, let me
write it down, and then you
see if you can guess
it, Brady.
BRADY HARAN: OK.
TONY PADILLA: [INAUDIBLE].
BRADY HARAN: You write it down.